nous faisons tous énormément d'erreurs
lorsqu'on utilise nos objets connectés
je vais donc vous montrer les sept
erreurs qu'on fait tous et bien
évidemment je vais vous donner toutes
les solutions pour venir vous protéger
et bien plus encore
la première chose qui est la base de la
base de la base de la base et qui est
extrêmement importante c'est que la
plupart du temps on ne met pas assez à
jour nos appareils à la maison quand je
dis appareil je pense bien évidemment à
votre smartphone ça va être votre
tablette ça va être votre montre ça va
même être votre box tout ce qui est
connecté tout ce qui vient communiquer
avec l'extérieur et bien de temps en
temps ça vaut le coup de regarder s'il y
a une mise à jour qui est faite parce
que les pirates utilisent énormément les
failles de sécurité qu'on peut retrouver
dans les logiciels et ces mises à jour
viennent apporter des patchs correctifs
qui font que globalement ça devrait bien
se passer
le deuxième point qui est extrêmement
important qui est aussi la base de la
base de la base c'est que on ne vient
pas assez se protéger avec des outils
adéquats quand je parle d'outils je
parle d'antivirus et il y a une légende
qui fait souvent penser que sur Mac on
n'a pas besoin d'antivirus je vous
assure que c'est faux ça veut pas dire
pour autant quoi dire vous attaquer
demain mais pensez à mettre en antivirus
sur votre Mac également un VPN alors
vous me direz un VPN chez vous vous en
avez pas nécessairement besoin mais
lorsque vous allez sur un réseau public
je pense par exemple un hack do ou dans
un hôtel et bien il y a une attaque très
connue qui s'appelle le man in the
middle qui va venir générer un réseau
qui correspondra peu au pro au nom du
réseau sur lequel vous êtes ou du moins
sur lequel vous voulez aller ça pourrait
être un McDo vie soit un truc comme ça
vous le voyez vous connecter pas besoin
d'identifiant et la personne en réalité
récupérera tout votre trafic avec un VP
vous allez venir chiffrer vos données ça
sera donc beaucoup plus compliqué pour
un pirate pour venir récupérer vos
données et pour vous protéger de toutes
les menaces en ligne vous accompagnez
dans votre vie numérique la Fnac a créé
une solution super intéressante et très
pertinente qui s'appelle Fnac vie
digital c'est une solution pour toute la
famille qui vous permet d'avoir une
protection complète pour votre sécurité
en ligne qui comprend un antivirus avec
FCQ un VPN pour venir sécuriser votre
connexion mais il y a également un
gestionnaire de mots de passe disposez
en plus d'une protection de
l'utilisateur avec une solution
anti-fishing une protection bancaire un
contrôle parental mais également une
protection d'identité mais en plus de ça
la Fnac a décidé de vous donner accès à
son réseau d'expert Fnac ça se passe sur
rendez-vous et vous y répondre à toutes
les questions relatives à votre vie
numérique que ça soit des conseils
d'après vente sur l'utilisation d'un
produit mon ordinateur est lent
qu'est-ce que je dois faire j'arrive pas
à connecter mon imprimante bref toutes
les questions qui concernent votre vie
numérique et bien vous aurez un expert
du labo Fnac qui vous répondra et en
plus de ça vous avez l'adhésion qui est
incluse à Fnac plus avec tous les
avantages que ça va venir vous offrir
des offres et des remises exclusives et
la livraison offerte sur tous vos achats
sur Fnac.com Fnac vue Digital est une
solution complète pour toute la famille
disponible sur tous vos appareils
connectés jusqu'à 10 appareils et ça
quel que soit votre OS et c'est surtout
une offre sans engagement au tarif de
9,99 € par mois ou 99 euros par an là où
si vous preniez tous vos abonnements
individuellement ça vous coûterait 230
euros par an avec snack vigital vous les
avez pour seulement 99 euros sur une
année mais il existe également deux
formules qui vous permettent d'avoir
Microsoft 365 soit un abonnement
personnel soit un abonnement pour toute
la famille vous avez donc à venir
découvrir Fnac vie digital je vous mets
bien évidemment un lien juste en bas
dans la description
le troisième point aussi super important
et on y pense pas assez on a souvent
tendance à venir cliquer sur des liens
trop rapidement et au moment où on se
rend compte et bien c'est trop tard ça
s'appelle des tentatives de phishing
c'est de l'âme sondage en français
qu'est-ce qui se passe un pirate a déjà
piraté par exemple sur Facebook ça
arrive très souvent et bien le compte de
votre ami il vous envoie un message
tiens j'ai vu cette photo de toi je suis
hyper surpris et vous avez un lien vous
vous dites waouh qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
à quoi ils ont eu accès vous cliquez
dessus et en fait là vous êtes tombé
dans le piège ce qui fait que la
personne va pouvoir venir récupérer
l'accès à votre compte sans même que
vous vous en soyez aperçu c'est valable
bien évidemment je vous parle de
Facebook mais valable sur tous les
réseaux sociaux voilà bien évidemment
par email quand vous voyez un message un
petit peu trop émotionnel et pas
personnalisé faites attention sur
Facebook ne cliquez pas sur les réseaux
sociaux ne cliquez pas envoyez un petit
message pour venir échanger avec la
personne poser des questions un peu
perso pour être sûr que c'est bien la
personne que vous connaissez qui est
derrière si vous recevez un email
officiel peut-être le gouvernement ça
peut être votre banque ça peut être
n'importe quoi regardez s'il y a des
fautes d'orthographe attention parce
qu'ici les pirates sont de plus en plus
attention à la syntaxe ne cliquez pas
astuce que je vous conseille c'est pour
recevoir un lien par email et bien vous
allez directement sur le site et c'est
le gouvernement et bien vous allez sur
le site du gouvernement vous allez sur
le site direct sans passer par le lien
si c'est votre banque vous allez
directement sur le site de votre banque
vous les contactez vous vérifiez vous ne
cliquez pas sur les liens vous faites
extrêmement attention il existe aussi
une petite astuce lorsque vous recevez
un email et bien vous allez voir dans le
nom de l'expéditeur qu'il correspond
bien au message si c'est cohérent si
vous recevez un message de votre banque
et que c'est envoyé à partir d'un email
un petit peu bizarre et bien vous saurez
qu'effectivement et bien c'est pas votre
banque qui vous l'envoyer alors
attention parce que une adresse email
peut être usurpée et vous pourriez
croire qu'effectivement si bien votre
banque au gouvernement qui vous l'envoie
attention aussi aux arnaques avec
Netflix il y en a énormément pensez donc
à vous rendre sur le site en question
plutôt que cliquez sur le lien ça pourra
réellement vous éviter quelques
déconvenues
la quatrième erreur qu'on fait tous on
ne fait pas assez attention à nos mots
de passe soit parce qu'on a un mot de
passe qui est trop facile à venir
deviner soit parce que vous ne changez
pas assez régulièrement votre mot de
passe ou soit encore pire parce que vous
utilisez le même mot de passe pour tous
les sites quasiment et bien ça c'est une
très très mauvaise idée il faut que vous
utilisiez des mots de passe qui sont
longs compliqués à deviner avec plein de
caractères spéciaux et surtout je vous
le dis je vous le redis je vous le redis
nous recyclez pas vos mots de passe ça
veut dire que vous allez avoir toute une
quantité de mot de passe la plupart du
temps extrêmement compliqué à deviner et
donc pour un seul homme ou une seule
femme c'est compliqué je vous conseille
donc de venir utiliser ici un
gestionnaire de mots de passe qui fera
le boulot à votre place vous n'aurez
donc plus qu'à tenir un seul mot de
passe qui lui-même doit être compliqué
pour venir se connecter à votre outil de
gestionnaire mot de passe et lui fera le
taf derrière parce que le gros risque
c'est que vous pouvez vous bien
évidemment vous faire pirater et qu'un
pirate justement intercède votre mot de
passe mais c'est pas le plus gros risque
le plus gros risque c'est qu'un site web
se fasse pirater et qu'il récupère toute
une liste d'emails et de mots de passe
et qu'est-ce que va faire un pirate à ce
moment-là et bien il va se dire ce mot
de passe là il peut être utilisé partout
sur plein de sites donc il va aller
typiquement sur un site très connu pour
venir vérifier il va aller sur Amazon il
est à votre identifiant votre adresse
email il va taper le mot de passe et si
là il arrive à rentrer dedans il n'aura
plus qu'à ensuite changer le mot de
passe pour que vous ne puissiez plus
vous y avoir accès et pour voir si un
plaisir avec sa liste de courses puisque
la plupart du temps votre carte bleue
est enregistrée alors même s'il existe
des systèmes de vérification lors de vos
achats par carte bleue et bien il se
peut que des fois ça passe au travers et
qu'à cause d'utilisation d'un mot de
passe unique qu'un pirate puisse avoir
accès à tous vos services en ligne et ça
croyez-moi on le souhaite pas je ne veux
pas vous le voulez pas personne ne le
veut le pirate le veut mais nous on ne
veut pas penser donc à utiliser ici un
gestionnaire de passe
la cinquième erreur on n'utilise pas ici
la double authentification on appellera
la 2fa ou la vérification en double
facteur vous pouvez par exemple utiliser
un système comme Google Authenticator il
en existe d'autres également qui vont
venir générer des clés souvent aussi
chiffres qui vont se renouveler dans le
temps toutes les 30 secondes toutes les
20 secondes toutes les minutes si bien
que lorsque vous allez dire vous
connecter à un service vous entrez votre
email vous entrez votre mot de passe on
vous demande en plus ici de rentrer
votre clé de fa qui va être généré
régulièrement et qui permettra de
certifier que vous avez le matériel et
que c'est bien vous ça ajoute ici une
couche de sécurité supplémentaire et qui
croyez-moi pourra réellement venir vous
protéger en ligne
la sixième erreur qu'on
fait pour provenance ça peut paraître du
bon sens mais on est très nombreux à se
faire avoir là-dessus ne télécharger des
fichiers que sur des sites sécurisés que
vous connaissez typiquement des
catalogues d'applications chez Apple ça
va être l'absor sur un smartphone
Android le Play Store Google bref
vérifiez toujours la source depuis
laquelle vous allez venir télécharger
parce que il se peut que le programme
que vous vouliez télécharger n'est pas
réellement celui que vous allez avoir et
puis attention si vous avez une arnaque
qui est un peu élaboré il se peut qu'une
copie d'un site web créé par un pirate
ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau au
site officiel Netflix par exemple qui en
plus de vouloir vous faire installer un
programme pour avoir accès à votre
ordinateur avec un cheval de Troie peut
aussi tenter de récupérer vos
identifiants en disant entrez votre
Identifiant votre mot de passe comme ça
on récupère tout
la septième erreur qu'on fait tous c'est
qu'on n'est pas assez méfiant attention
ici aux arnaques téléphoniques avec les
scamers qui vont faire passer pour
Netflix qui vont se faire passer pour
Microsoft si on a identifié que vous
avez un problème dans votre PC on est la
société Microsoft on vous propose de
vous aider si ça et ça et ça alors vous
vous avez pas vous en douter vous allez
tomber dans le piège il vous poseront
plein de questions il prendront même
l'accès à votre PC et infini ils
pourront faire ce qu'ils veulent ils
auront accès à tout vérifiez toujours si
la personne qui vous appelle et bien
celle qu'elle prétend être dans l'idéal
lorsque vous appelle rappelez la hotline
officielle derrière pour être sûr que
c'est bien eux soyez méfiant et pensez
toujours à vérifier à vérifier vérifier
vérifier et attention parce que les
pirates sont très bien organisés seront
réellement venir vous parler vous dire
mais non bien évidemment on n'est pas
des pirates on est la société en
question vous pouvez être tranquille
soyez rassuré vérifiez vérifier vérifier
allez un petit bonus 8ème erreur qu'on
fait tous et bien c'est qu'on dit
beaucoup trop sur nous en ligne sur les
réseaux sociaux par exemple on a trop
facilement tendance à poster des moments
qu'on aime et c'est normal parce que
c'est des moments qu'on aime et qu'on
veut partager avec nos amis sauf que en
réalité il y a pas que nos amis qui
regardent ça première chose à faire
penser à modifier vos paramètres de
confidentialité lorsque vous publiez ce
sont vos amis et uniquement vos amis et
puis pensez aussi un truc tout bête les
amis de jour peuvent être les ennemis du
lendemain alors il faut pas être parano
pour autant mais il peut arriver dans la
vie qu'on se brouille avec quelqu'un et
que une personne mal intentionnée
récupère des infos sur nous enfin c'est
le premier point ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut se méfier de tout et tout le monde
mais soyez quand même vigilant et puis
le deuxième point si vous ne faites pas
attention à vos paramètres de
confidentialité vous postez des photos
sur vous votre famille une piscine chez
vous un transatie des bouts de votre
maison pensez vraiment que les pirates
sont très malins et peuvent réussir à
vous identifier avec des outils d'usine
on peut réellement venir vous retrouver
très facilement et puis il y a rien de
pire tu es arrivé un moment marquant on
est bien arrivé à l'autre bout du monde
en vacances avec toute la famille ça
veut dire que la maison est vide les
pirates seront et au-delà des pirates il
peut y avoir cambriolages derrière donc
faites réellement attention à ce que
vous venez publier sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que là c'est vous qui
livrez les informations sur un plateau
d'argent au pirates cambrioleur et que
ça j'ai encore et puis autre truc est
super important
publié sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui de plus en plus
d'entreprises lors des phases de
recrutement vont faire appel à des
sociétés d'usine qui leur permettra de
venir étudier vous différentes
publications et votre vie numérique si
bien que s'ils arrivent à trouver une
vieille photo de vous je ne sais comment
avec des choses compromettantes et bien
c'est pas forcément foufou le droit à
l'oubli sur internet ça existe dans les
faits c'est beau mais en réalité c'est
pas réellement ça donc faites vraiment
attention à ce que vous venez publier
sur le web
allez je vous donne quelques astuces en
plus qui vous permettront d'aller encore
plus loin en termes de sécurisation de
vos données et qui vous permettront de
bien vous protéger par rapport au
hackers la première chose c'est penser à
faire des sauvegardes si vous avez un
ordinateur qui a un rançon noir qui est
abîmé qui a été piraté qui est explosé
qui n'est plus utilisable et bien si
vous n'avez pas fait une sauvegarde sur
un autre support physique à côté un
disque dur un As ou que ça j'ai encore
ou même pourquoi pas dans le Cloud et
bien au moment vous risquerez réellement
de vous endormes les doigts alors
attention ici une clé USB n'est pas un
espace de stockage pérenne pensez
vraiment à prendre un disque dur
méfiez-vous aussi des emails que vous
allez recevoir de votre banque Votre
banque vous enverra pas des emails avec
des liens Cliqua pour partir si ça et ça
non lorsque vous recevez des
communications de votre banque c'est à
vous de vous rendre directement sur le
site de votre banque sans passer par un
quelconc client qui serait très
probablement une tentative d'arsonade
autre astuce importante pensez
réellement à venir consulter
régulièrement vos comptes bancaires pour
être sûr qu'on vous aurez pas dépouillé
d'une certaine somme et qu'il n'aurait
pas réussi malgré les sécurités en place
à venir utiliser votre carte bleue ça
peut paraître bon sens mais ne mettez
pas de clé USB que vous ne connaissez
pas dans l'un de vos appareils attention
ici au Rubert de kick est un logiciel
caché à l'intérieur de la clé USB que
vous ne verrez pas mais qui pourtant
fera de réel dégâts autre élément
extrêmement important n'utilisez pas de
câble pour ni recharger votre smartphone
que vous ne connaissez pas soit c'est
votre cas c'est le cas de l'ami proche
soit vous n'utilisez pas de câble vous
n'allez pas par exemple dans un uber
venir utiliser le cap qu'on vous donne
vous n'allez pas dans un hôtel utilisez
le câble qui est posé que vous ne
connaissez pas n'utilisez pas de câbles
que vous ne connaissez pas pourquoi
parce que vous donnez un accès sans même
vous en rendre compte à votre matériel
vous branchez en physique une porte
d'entrée à votre matériel et ça on le
souhaite pas pensez également à venir
vérifier le chiffrage de votre Wi-Fi à
la maison pensez bien évidemment
utiliser des clés longues pour votre
Wi-Fi celle qui vous est fournie
d'origine ira très bien n'allez pas vous
dire oui mais je retiens pas c'est
compliqué je vais mettre une très courte
non parce que même ici avec une attaque
brute force on pourrait venir rentrer
dans votre système et avoir accès à
l'intégralité de votre maison n'utilisez
pas ici de clé web utiliser de la vpa2
et puis le mieux du mieux du mieux du
mieux c'est de faire une liste blanche
c'est à dire que vous n'allez autoriser
que tous les appareils que vous
connaissez par exemple je vais voir ma
Google home je m'autorise ma télé je
l'autorise mon pc mon mac je autorise
bon smartphone je l'autorise tout ça
grâce à votre adresse mac qui est
l'adresse physique de votre matériel si
bien qu'une personne qui arriverait à
rentrer dans le système et bien ne
pourrait pas se connecter pourquoi parce
que son appareil ne serait pas autorisé
et puis un autre point qui est important
transmettez ces connaissances par les
gens autour de vous dites-leur est-ce
que tu as fait ça ne fait pas ça faites
attention éduquer vos enfants
expliquez-leur la cybersécurité
montrez-leur les risques et de la même
manière qu'on va leur dire de faire
attention aux réseaux sociaux et bien
faites attention à ce que vous allez
faire avec votre appareil attention wifi
public et puis si vous êtes en
Travailleur indépendant vous allez pas
forcément investir dans la cybersécurité
ça coûte cher pensez quand même de temps
en temps à faire appel à une société
spécialisée qui viendra vérifier votre
installation et puis je vous invite bien
évidemment à venir consulter le site du
gouvernement sur la cybersécurité avec
plein d'informations super pertinentes
vous avez également fait une vidéo sur
les sept erreurs qui explosent vos yeux
lorsque vous utilisez vos appareils
c'est super important allez la voir vous
m'en direz des nouvelles